- I heard that actually was it you two,
you play guitar, and y'all
kept everybody entertained,
right, during the shoot?
- There was some music that we had,
but mostly it was Jeff at
the piano and people kind
of like joining him 'cause
he can play anything,
and it was a lot of fun, a lot of fun.
- I like to play, he's a musical genius.
There was a whole evening, a one man show.
If you give him a guitar.
- [Kelly] I had no idea.
- Oh yeah, he's great.
- I know, I didn't know you played.
- Yes, he is.
- Sings, does all kinds of stuff.
- And you sing, how did I miss this?
- I don't, when Kelly
Clarkson asks you if you sing,
you better be able to sing.
And I can't sing.
- I'm just saying, it
could be a trio moment now
cause I didn't know he could do that, too.
(crowd cheering)
- He sings great.
- I'm in, I'll do it.
- And DeWanda sings,
DeWanda's a wonderful singer.
DeWanda sang with us.
- Again, I echo what Chris just said,
when Kelly Clark asks if you can sing.
- Everyone is backing out.
Everyone is like, I'm not
going karaoking with you.
- I will, I'll karaoke.
- I love karaoke, it's so,
well obviously a whole show I
started with it, but I love
it 'cause it's funny to do
like songs people don't
expect, so I usually rap.
What do you do at karaoke?
- Oh man, you know, it kind of
depends on how much I've been
what I've been drinking and
how much I've been drinking.
- Yes, there is a difference
between like beer and alcohol,
like liquor.
- Yeah, I'm Whitney Houston
when I'm really drunk.
But you know, I'm like
"Pour Some Sugar on Me"
when I'm just buzzed.
- [Kelly] Yes, okay, okay.